like one thing that a lot of people
might be interested in is that you're a
foreigner working in like
the anime and manga industry in japan
you're basically leaving the web dream
yeah basically yeah so like
how did how did that happen how did you
find a job in book walker katakawa
as a foreigner you know i i know this i
think i know the answer to this
craigslist tokyo tokyo
do you want to tell the story about how
that happened oh well i was working at a
marketing consulting company in japan
right because you've been living here
because you had married to a japanese
person well yeah like my first second
year in japan but
um yeah i was working at a marketing
digital marketing
agency being a consultant for several
different japanese companies who wanted
to like
get i don't know foreign not foreign
global traffic to their site or
something yeah i just said that was that
would count as foreign yeah
i don't know what you're freaking calm
down am i sweating
on the table just fine
where was i are you talking about the
global oh yeah
[ __ ] you threw me off and now i'm like
wait what was i even talking about you
were talking about how you got the job
at bulk
oh yeah and then okay and then i needed
a bicycle one day and i finished my work
and it was like during lunch time and i
was like oh i can just check craigslist
for you know cheap bicycle
like 30 bucks 20 bucks i'm checking on
craigslist and then i found the bicycle
i didn't buy it though and then i was
like oh i wonder if there's like
actually
legit jobs on craigslist besides like
foot massage whatever it is looking for
f
yeah because you know that's the image
that craigslist has in america
yeah yeah yeah or or a fridge full of
coffee yeah you're the one
who made me get that [ __ ] fridge
cockroach when you buy something on
craigslist you first look at it in
person and then you decide i'm not going
to some
[ __ ] person's house to check out a
ten dollar fridge maybe why didn't you
amazon it
then because well now he knows better
well now
he knows i really insisted that this the
cockroaches the craigslist
may as well be a cockroach this changed
my life you were so consistent
so insisted that craigslist dude you
should really go to craigslist man
you're going to get a mad deal i was
like
fine meline fine i'll get i'll get a
fridge from craigslist
and then it got [ __ ] cockroaches in
it maybe but now you have a story
i do have a story yeah
i hate you so so this job what did it
say what what jobs did you find on there
oh i think it's like looking for f
in our area it said like digital
manga marketing specialist and i was
like what
they're looking for something like that
i click it and it doesn't say the name
of the company
it says like oh chiodaku ibashi and i'm
like wait there's only two publishers
that i know of
in this area and i was like it's either
this really big one or like this
kind of a biggest one and i google all
the
well i knew it was katakallah so i was
like oh i'm going to google every single
katakawa
like department and see what they're
like
what they're looking for and then i
found before and it matched exactly
kind of what the craigslist thing was
which was
oh looking for someone to go overseas to
different anime conventions
to like market our store and i'm like i
love it
yeah native english no japanese required
and this was like
four five five years ago and like my
japanese is nowhere fluent
and at that time it was even more
horrible so
getting into the anime industry or manga
industry you need to like speak
english or not english i'm japanese
japanese yeah and japanese like
fluently yeah beyond business and uh
so i was like oh i'm never gonna work in
the manga street unless it's like in
america then i can like
yeah why'd you got it oh yeah that's
that's like insane
because if i saw that adam ad on
craigslist
again i would like think it was a scam
or something yeah like imagine cater cow
going on
like advertising a [ __ ] job on
craigslist
they didn't say the company name though
but it's still
on craigslist i remember why are you
laughing
i suck dick for videos like
i wanted to see what was on there and so
i found this ad that was like uh looking
for youtubers
uh below ten thousand and i was like
what
yeah this is in london so i called them
up and it was what no no not japan
i don't know okay i don't feel weird
about that in japan and so i caught them
up and they were like yeah
we want to pay youtubers uh below ten
thousand dollars uh
uh below ten thousand subscribers five
thousand dollars to move to our platform
exclusively i called there's a woman on
the phone
i didn't tell her i had like a million
subs and she was just like she was going
on and she was like
yeah so uh we just need you to be in an
exclusive deal with our partners
and and all this and i was so confused i
was like what the [ __ ] i never heard of
this platform
and then they were like oh yeah but uh
because i was a guy obviously yeah but
we're only interested in women as well
and i was like
that's like red flags coming up yeah
yeah
i don't know i wonder if i'd like
stumbled onto like the greatest like
prostitution network or something i
don't know what it was to do
yeah to say i still don't know i have
the phone call recorded on my pc
yeah and then i told them at a million
subs and then they uh they were like oh
no we're not interested
why two thousand well i was really
confused about that
is it because like if like you know they
they want to like drop out for example
if there's like drama they're like oh
this guy's gonna go ten thousand
subscribers they won't go anywhere they
kept saying stuff that was like too good
to be true they were like
we'll give you five thousand dollars to
move we were in the uk as well by the
way that was already like
that's weird and then also they were
like we can give you premium ad
rev rates of like 10 cpm i'm like get
out of here
[ __ ] off no way i was losing it i
i wish to this day i still want to know
what that was i don't know why i told
that you even checked
like their website thoroughly they
wouldn't tell me what it was they were
like it's on it's download it's on the
download and i'm like that's weird
this sounds that sounds sketch as [ __ ]
that sounds scary that sounds like uh
it's like it sounds like a hiring ring
for like a prostitution
like a black market prostitution that's
why that's why i never want to use
craigslist
because every single story of her from
craigslist is apart from yours
the section where you can you know pay
for favors you can
oh yeah yeah oh no that's like the
community or something like that there's
one where it's like for old people it's
all just like 40
50 year old women looking for like dudes
to just give them a good is this this
isn't
in japan uh yeah yeah and the uk
and the us i checked all of them because
i wanted to see if there's anything
crazy about craigslist
don't tell me you're going to make a
video okay thank god
so tell me that's where all the hot sexy
singles
in my area they're all incredible it's
not kiss anime god damn it
that's why you're not homesick what if
you just like what if you just
clicked on the kiss anime ads and it
just takes you to the crisis
it makes sense it's wild because there
was like 40 year old women who were
married
showing their face and giving their
mobile phone number and i was like whoa
you are playing with that
says that doesn't sound safe but also
you're married right yeah
i saw your face karen
every karen is like you don't know if
it's their real photo
yeah it might it could be very much a
scam definitely have to be their number
though right i mean
i don't know unless i guess we actually
have to find out my course
i would totally call her just for a
video i do that i mean i have like no
qualms about doing that like yeah
and i'm bad okay but like steering back
to the conversation sorry yes
yeah yeah back to the conversation so
like i i think we can all agree that
like maylene's story
is very much a rare case right like is
that a rare case
i think so i've never heard of anyone
getting into the anime industry through
craigslist
i think those people who you probably
most people know or you guys know
are in the us working for us yeah
was there ever time you were gonna you
wanted to work in the u.s industry
the most nervous smile i've ever seen
yeah i did there was
there was probably two companies that i
applied to that were
[ __ ] rejected did you get rejected
you're rejected is that why you
but they called back and they're like
you are the second candidate
that hurts even more i don't hear that
yeah
i was like when i was a fresh graduate
right do you want to know if you haven't
got the job i don't want to know i just
want to apply
i want to know no i want to move i also
like i don't know want to know the
reason
they're not going to give them they're
never going to give it to you guaranteed
to every person who dropped they said
you were the second one
guarantee honestly we wanted to we
wanted to really that's what i would do